how about somebody that will stand up
for gay rights marriage equality
let's stop dropping bombs let's legalize
marijuana let's take on crony capitalism
come on the system's not fair
wake up Democrats do do good at what
you're supposed to do good at the
libertarians believe that you are free
to do whatever you want with your bodies
be whoever you want
the libertarian party is is socially
very liberal the Democratic Party had an
option to elect somebody who was more of
a populist who actually represented
people and they chose not to they chose
to rigged the game and and box out the
one nominee who actually inspired
passion in people actually libertarians
have a natural affinity with Bernie
Sanders supporters I can know from my
own personal US Senate campaign I've
gotten a huge response from Bernie
supporters because we agree on ending
the war on drugs we agree on NSA
surveillance we agree on a host of
issues that Hillary doesn't represent I
think Bernie Sanders has brought a lot
of message that does resonate with
libertarians that we share his he has
joined in opposition to the drug war he
has called for police reform he's
generally not perfectly but generally
anti-war the thing about Bernie Sanders
is that he's a genuine human being I may
not agree with everything he has to say
I'm sure my supporters will agree that
he has to say but they believe in him
because he's a he said someone they can
connect with we have that here in the
elaborate Aryan party assuming Gary
Johnson is our nominee he has the
highest a cou rating as of 2012 when I
talked to my Bernie friends what I will
say is why would you want a government
with more power and and control and
bigger controlled by the very entities
that you don't like you know so I'm of
course addressing the banking corruption
I want to build up a wall between
corporation and state because I want to
end the economics of stimulus of
corporate welfare I want an end to the
war on drugs completely I want to get
the government out of our personal lives
I want to reign in the NSA
so while there may be issues that we
disagree on we can make movement on
issues that are very important to people
who are Bernie Sanders supporters that
are also very important to libertarian
such as myself if you want the
Democratic Party to get better on the
the reasons you support Democrats civil
liberties opposing foreign interventions
opposing crony capitalism you don't get
that bikes it giving a boat to Hillary
Clinton you get it by giving a boat to
the libertarians and providing that
incentive for them to get better and the
same goes on the Republican side that
has it worked for you in voting a
Democrat for the past 30 40 or however
many years you've been voting you might
try something different
I mean insanity is defined as doing the
same thing over and over and expecting
different results so if you feel that
you want to end the Foreign Wars you
want to bring us back to being a nation
at peace if you want to end the racist
war on drugs if you want to actually get
to the core problems of poverty in this
country of wealth inequality of you know
college tuition these problems are
problems that the libertarians have a
solution for and it's one that would
actually put more money back in people's
pockets and make this generation not be
in a position where they might actually
make less money than their parents